solve for X and we have 5x plus 7 is
greater than 3 times X plus 1 so let's
just try to isolate X on one side of
this inequality but before we do that
let's just simplify this right-hand side
so we get 5x plus 7 is greater than
let's distribute this 3 so 3 times X
plus 1 is the same thing as 3 times X
plus 3 times 1 so it's going to be 3x
plus 3 times 1 is 3 now if we want to
put our X's on the left hand side we can
subtract 3x from both sides that'll get
rid of this 3x on the right hand side so
let's do that
let's subtract 3x from both sides and we
get on the left-hand side 5x minus 3x is
2x plus 7 is greater than 3x minus 3x
those cancel out that was the whole
point behind subtracting 3x from both
sides is greater than 3 is greater than
3 now we can subtract 7 from both sides
to get rid of this positive 7 right over
here so let's subtract let's subtract 7
from both sides and we get on the
left-hand side 2x plus 7 minus 7 is just
2x is greater than 3 minus 7 which is
negative 4 and then let's see we have 2x
is greater than negative 4 if we just
want an X over here we can divide both
sides by 2 since 2 is a positive number
we don't have to swap the inequality so
let's just divide both sides by 2 and we
get X is greater than negative 4 divided
by 2 is negative 2 so the solution will
look like this draw the number line I
can draw a straighter number line than
that there we go still not that great
but it'll serve our purposes so let's
say that's negative 3 negative 2
negative 1 0 1 2 3 X is greater than
negative 2 it does not include negative
2 it is not greater than or equal to
negative 2 so we have to exclude
negative 2
and we exclude negative two by drawing
an open circle at negative two but then
all of the values greater than that are
valid X's that would solve that would
satisfy this inequality so anything
above it anything above it will work and
let's just try let's try this just try
something that should work and then
let's try something else that will
shouldn't work so zero should work it is
greater than negative two it's right
over here so let's verify that five
times zero plus seven should be greater
than three times zero plus one so this
is seven because this is just a zero
seven should be greater than 3 right 3
times 1 so 7 should be greater than 3
and it definitely is now let's try
something that should not work let's try
negative 3 so 5 times negative 3 5 times
negative 3 plus 7 let's see if it's
greater than 3 times negative 3 plus 1
so this is negative 15 plus 7 is
negative 8 that is negative 8 let's see
if that is greater than negative 3 plus
1 is negative 2 times 3 is negative 6
negative 8 is not is not greater than
negative 6 negative 8 is more negative
than negative 6 it's less than so it's
good that negative 3 didn't work because
we didn't include that in our solution
set so we tried something that is in our
solution set and it did work and
something that's not and it didn't work
so we're feeling pretty good